I came here to meet an extraordinary man
whose vision stretches far beyond
himself what I did
Vanga Kyla this is Isaac navona okay
action
Hatchin ah sir he's committed to
changing the country's image by making
incredibly violent action films that are
intended to knock you dead with laughter
he's a self-taught filmmaker in Uganda's
most prolific having made over 50
feature films okay and he's turned a few
square blocks of his neighborhood into a
fully functional studio backlog this is
impossible this should not exist I mean
you see like there's no plumbing
electricity was good for a while but now
it's still four days a week maybe making
movies possible okay why see you see my
name is Alan hawse manus is a super fan
who saw one of Isaac's films in a
Brooklyn bar one night and immediately
got on a plane to Uganda to meet the
genius behind it he never left
eventually becoming Isaac's co-producer
I think people are coming for the same
reason that I'm staying this reminds
people of why they love movies in the
first place like I'm not an actor but
you here for five minutes and you and
you want to do it you want to be a
commando you want to play
the most obvious theme in all of Isaac's
movies is brutal violence taken to
comedic extremes and that's exactly the
point
violence as an artistic expression Isaac
believes is not only his creative
passion but also his country's salvation
the picture I went to Korea right now
Uganda is known for it I mean being that
time it I mean killed people we have
also to kill people to to to to to to
rub off that what that image by the
image of a demean you want to clear the
picture of Uganda is killing people by
making films of Uganda is killing people
of course yes
and we can I think we we're going to
succeed in that way Isaac's over-the-top
filmmaking style strikes a chord here
driving modest movie ticket and DVD
sales which the actors are also able to
sell toward a door there by supporting
the crew and their families an Isaac
isn't just a local celebrity he's an
international phenomenon with millions
of hits on YouTube to confirm his
intensely devoted fan base even more
devoted or the people who come from all
over Uganda to help create his micro
low-budget full-length films Wow guys
this is so impressive any filmmaker in
the world no matter how successful they
are would dream to have a team like you
guys
[Applause]
[Music]
you